[Musique]
d'abord c'est un défi en fait ça
commence comme ça c'est une expérience
de vie qu'on peut partager et qui
consiste à faire une pause avec toute
consommation alcoolique pendant environ
un
mois je vous conseille d'essayer de
faire ça en groupe c'est plus sympa vous
pouvez le faire en famille vous pouvez
le faire avec des amis vous pouvez aussi
le faire directement via des réseaux
sociaux il y a des groupes qui se créent
pour ça parce que c'est plus sympa et
c'est plus Mo
ça c'est la première chose c'est pas
faire tout seul parce que c'est plus fun
la deuxième c'est c'est d'anticiper sa
consommation en fait pour sortir des
habitudes sortir des automatismes quand
vous allez un afterw avec des collègues
souvent vous arrivez vous assayez vous
dites qu'est-ce qu'on vous propose une
bière vous réfléchissez même pas ce que
vous voulez consommer et là c'est ce qui
est bien dans ce défi justement c'est
que vous allez revenir en pleine
conscience et décider ce que vous allez
consommer les gens se rendent pas compte
mais en à peine un mois les gens la
plupart des gens qui qui qui ont arrêté
le 10 ils ils ont un meilleur
comportement de sommeil c'est ils
dorment beaucoup mieux par impact quand
on dort mieux on a une meilleure humeur
on a une meilleure concentration on a
beaucoup de choses comme ça la deuxième
le deuxième gros avantage sans ça
s'explique vraiment parce que les gens
le disent c'est une sensation d'aller
mieux physiologiquement ça s'explique
parce que pas de consommation d'alcool
moins de cholestérol euh moins de sucre
dans le sang baisse de la pression
sanguine bref forcément tout ça ça va
mieux on sent mieux en forme on peut
faaire du sport plus facilement et puis
le trème petit avantage comme je vous ai
dit surtout après les fêtes pas de
consommation d'alcool
[Musique]
économie